Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambhudassa
Hommage au Bouddha, à celui qui est pleinement et complètement réalisé par lui-même.
Je vais tenter de démystifier
l'enseignement prodigué sur le non-soi et je ne vais vraisemblablement pas réussir mais ça ne sera pas sans avoir eu la volonté d'essayer tout au moins dans les légendes qui entourent l'awakening du Bouddha
Dans les légendes autour de la réalisation du Bouddha, quand il s'approcha de ses compagnons antérieurs, dans un premier temps, ils ne voulaient même pas l'accueillir.
Après tout, il avait quitté la vie ascétique, il avait devenu pauvre.
Après tout, il avait quitté la vie ascétique et il était devenu faible.
Mais ils avaient l'impression que quelque chose avait changé dans cet homme et donc ils ne pouvaient pas mettre le doigt dessus et ils lui préparèrent néanmoins et quand même le siège de l'enseignant.
Et il donna son premier discours en décrivant la base de ses enseignements.
Maintenant, nous ne savons pas ce qu'il a en fait dit.
en fait nous ne savons pas exactement ce qu'il enseigne mais il a été dit qu'il s'agissait des quatre nobles vérités qui sont alors rappelez-vous le fait de l'insatisfaction la cause de l'insatisfaction
et la cause de cette insatisfaction est le désir erroné ou faux et qu'en fait il peut y avoir une fin à la souffrance et ensuite le chemin permettant d'accéder à la fin de cette souffrance à la fin de ce discours Kandanya
Et à la fin de ce discours, Kandanya, un de ses anciens compagnons, eut une première réalisation.
Et le Bouddha s'exclama de joie, Anya Kandanya.
Anya veut dire celui qui sait.
Mais les quatre autres anciens compagnons demeurèrent quand même dans un état d'ignorance.
Et donc, ils firent le tour de l'aumône pour aller récolter de la nourriture.
Maintenant, peut-être que c'était à cause de cette...
refurbishment of the stomach that the Buddha again gave a second talk and they all became fully liberated.
Mais c'est peut-être grâce au fait qu'ils s'étaient bien nourris après cette partie d'Arms Round que les quatre autres devinrent pleinement réalisés à leur tour.
Now he gave a talk
par lequel les autres devinrent complètement libérés.
Et cela est connu comme la caractéristique de non-soi.
En premier lieu, il faut bien se rendre compte de ce que signifiait à ce moment-là un atta, ce qui veut dire en fait, oui, atta, ce qui veut en fait dire soi ou moi.
Et en cette période-là de temps, Atta, en fait, était plutôt à considérer comme l'âme.
Et quelles étaient donc les caractéristiques de l'âme à cette époque-là ?
La première est que c'était éternel.
La première caractéristique, c'était que l'âme était éternelle.
Et bien maintenant, si quelque chose est éternelle, ça signifie que ça ne change pas.
Et que ça ne change pas en autre chose.
C'est vrai?
If it changes, it must be something else from what it was.
Et si cela change, ça doit forcément être quelque chose d'autre par rapport à ce qui avait été avant.
Number one.
Number two, it was always happy.
Et en deuxième lieu, la caractéristique suivante, c'est que l'âme était toujours bienheureuse, en continuité heureuse.
Et la raison de cela, c'est parce que l'âme était en contrôle d'elle-même, somme toute.
et donc en fait ça veut dire qu'il n'y a pas le phénomène de séparation ou de dualité au sein de l'âme et ça veut dire qu'elle est pleine et entière en elle-même et en elle-même
Elle est en un état de perfection.
La perfection et l'éternité vont ensemble.
Et la troisième chose, c'est que c'était le vrai.
C'était le vrai, au contraire de ce monde phénoménal,
Et la troisième caractéristique, c'était que cette âme, c'était ce qu'il y avait de vrai, et tout le reste de ce monde-ci, ce n'était que, c'était faux, c'était illusion.
Ah, pardon.
Ce qui était vrai, et en opposition, le monde n'est pas vrai.
Oui.
Et par opposition, le monde n'est pas réel.
Pardon, il me corrige.
C'est pas réel, le monde.
Ok.
Donc, le Bouddha dit, « Investigatez-vous.
» Et il nous a donné des outils pour y arriver.
Il...
Il lit dans cinq tas, cinq catégories, ce qu'est en fait, ce que constitue être un être humain.
Alors le mot le plus adapté c'est agrégat parce qu'en fait chaque agrégat est constitué de plusieurs choses.
Et le premier agrégat est le corps.
Tout d'abord, est-ce que le corps change ?
Alors les physiciens d'aujourd'hui qui sont nos nouveaux dieux nous disent que notre corps
Intégrant toutes les cellules du corps, se transforme et se remplace entièrement en l'espace de sept ans.
La prochaine fois que vous vous regardez dans une glace, dites-vous à vous-même, ce visage n'était pas ici il y a sept ans.
Dites-vous bien qu'il y a sept ans, le visage que vous percevez n'était pas là il y a sept années en arrière.
Alors, quel que soit ce que constituait le visage il y a sept ans, tout cela a complètement disparu.
Pouvons-nous
Est-ce que nous avons le contrôle sur le corps pour réussir à atteindre la paix ou tout au moins des expériences qui soient plaisantes ou au minimum neutres ?
Alors il vous pose la question, est-ce que...
Alors dans le cas justement de contrôle et de bonheur, le corps ne peut pas nous le donner.
Et quand on dit le réel, on veut dire la substance.
Et quand on dit réel, on veut dire substance.
Et la substance, c'est une philosophie que vous avez en même temps à l'Est comme à l'Ouest.
Alors la substance est quelque chose qui se trouve en dessous de ce qui est apparent.
Et en philosophie, ils parlent de substance d'un côté et d'attribut de l'autre côté.
La distinction entre les deux est le meilleur exemple de la distinction entre les deux.
est la compréhension catholique de ce qui se passe dans l'Eucharistie.
L'Eucharistie, oui.
À la pointe où le prêtre bénit le Président,
au moment où le curé donne sa bénédiction à the host you mean the bread ah the bread sorry l'hostie l'hostie it remains it keeps the attributes of bread cela conserve les attributs de pain but the substance has become the body of Christ
Mais la substance est devenue le corps du Christ.
Donc, dans l'entendu du Bouddha, pouvons-nous trouver cette substance sous le corps, comme nous l'expérimentons ?
En d'autres mots, si vous retirez les attributs de cette main, est-ce qu'il y a une main substantielle
Alors, si nous enlevons les attributs du corps, est-ce qu'on arrive à trouver la substance sous le corps ?
De même que pour la main, si on enlevait les attributs de la main, est-ce qu'on trouverait une substance à la main ?
Alors, selon nos scientifiques honorables, ceci n'est pas possible.
Alors, ceci n'est pas possible.
Mais quoi qu'il en soit, quel que soit atta, donc l'âme, et bien ce n'est de toute façon pas le corps.
Alors durant ces temps, et y compris pour le Bouddha, le corps mental était considéré comme séparé du corps physique.
et d'ailleurs lors de la mort c'est ce corps subtil qui quitte le corps physique mais en fait les mêmes questionnements peuvent se poser pour ce corps subtil
Maintenant, laissons cela à l'extérieur parce que c'est une question de si nous y croions ou non.
Si nous revenons au corps présent que nous avons, nous pouvons prendre les mêmes arguments pour le prochain aggregate qui est le ressenti.
Et maintenant nous pouvons reprendre les mêmes arguments pour l'agrégat suivant qui est le ressenti.
Alors, dans les enseignements du Bouddha, tous les ressentis dans le corps sont vedanas.
Védena, les sensations qui viennent du corps, comme la douleur.
Et il y a des sensations dans le corps qui viennent du corps, comme quand on se sent heureux.
Et il y a des ressentis, des émotions qui viennent de l'esprit, par exemple lorsqu'on se sent heureux.
Et tous ces états souffrent du même phénomène.
caractéristiques ils ne sont pas permanents ils sont constamment en train de changer ils n'ont aucune substance ils sont juste des sentiments fleetants et le plus important de notre point de vue
Et le plus important de notre point de vue, c'est qu'on ne peut pas les contrôler.
Et si on pouvait se dire à soi-même « Ah, maintenant, je ne vais plus jamais me mettre en colère » et puis que ça se passait ainsi, puis ça disparaissait.
Donc nous avons
très peu de contrôle sur nos émotions.
Pour la plupart, ce sont des réactions, des réactions apprises pour faire face à des situations.
Ensuite, nous arrivons au troisième agrégat.
Et maintenant, nous passons au troisième agrégat.
Et tout ça, ce sont nos perceptions.
Et nous pouvons mettre tous nos concepts
et toutes nos mémoires dans cet agrégat et là nous pouvons voir encore plus clairement que bien évidemment ce n'est pas notre âme en fait ils sont très passagers fugaces bien des choses de cet ordre là on les oublie ils n'ont pas de
Ils n'ont aucune substance.
Et à notre désarroi, durant la méditation, pas à désarroi, encore pire, à notre horreur, enfin, durant la méditation, on n'arrive pas à les contrôler.
Ensuite, nous arrivons au quatrième aggregat,
Et ensuite nous passons au quatrième agrégat qui sont nos sankaras.
Maintenant, sankaras sont nos habitudes.
Et ce sont les habitudes que nous créons à travers nos actes de volonté.
le corps n'est pas sous notre contrôle nos émotions et nos ressentis ne sont pas non plus sous notre contrôle oui et ressentis
Mais ces habitudes, on les a créées à travers un acte de volonté.
Alors ça peut être une habitude toute simple comme avoir envie d'avoir une boisson ou prendre une boisson toutes les dix minutes.
ça peut être une habitude d'être irritable chaque fois que l'on voit un lapin.
Quelle est la parole pour moule ?
Oui, toupe.
Ah non, toupe est une mousse.
Une moule est... Non, non, non, elle est vraie.
Ah, elle est vraie, d'accord.
Toupe.
Je ne sais pas comment le dire.
les taupes ont attaqué son gazon et pendant longtemps chaque fois que j'ai vu ces montagnes de moules j'ai devenu très irrité c'était ma décision
de devenir irrité à chaque fois que j'ai vu une de ces montagnes.
C'était ma décision de devenir irritable et chaque fois que je voyais ces tas de...
Une taupinière, merci !
Une taupinière.
Ah, c'est une petite montagne.
Donc, ces sankharas, ces habitudes, elles changent évidemment.
Alors, ces Shankaras, bien évidemment, ils se transforment.
Ils n'ont aucune substance parce qu'eux aussi, ils passent.
Alors, rappelez-vous que la définition de substance, c'est que ça ne change pas et ça ne passe pas.
Maintenant nous passons au cinquième agrégat qui est le dernier.
Et ça ce sont des actes de cognition.
Toutes les informations qui arrivent constamment au cerveau et à l'esprit
doit être intercepté sur un écran quel qu'il soit suffisamment longtemps pour qu'on puisse comprendre et le situer et ça, ça constitue un acte de cognition donc l'acte de cognition
change extraordinairement rapidement en fait cet acte de cognition se transforme selon le Bouddha d'une manière extraordinairement rapide c'est comme ces vieux films avec les bandes si le film va assez vite, il nous donne l'apparition de la continuité
Si le film va suffisamment vite, on a cette impression de continuité.
Et ainsi, ces actes de cognition se passent à un rythme tellement élevé qu'on a cette illusion ou cette impression de continuité.
Et cette continuité, quand étendue, devient un sentiment de moi.
Et cette impression de continuité, quand c'est étendu, donne lieu à cette impression de soi.
Et nous revenons à ceci dans un moment.
Alors le Bouddha veut qu'on investisse cet état psychophysique.
Psychophysique.
Psychophysique, oui.
Pas de problème.
de manière à pouvoir voir si effectivement il y a cette âme qui est présente excusez-moi, j'ai juste perdu la tête si il y a cette âme dans l'organisme psychophysique si l'âme réside dans cette forme psychophysique donc ce sont, devons-nous dire un des expériments que le Bouddha nous a mis
Et ça, c'est une des expériences, si on peut l'appeler ainsi, que le Bouddha nous propose.
Une coupe perpendiculaire.
et il veut aussi que nous investiguions ça comme un continuum dans le temps et ça il le fait à travers son enseignement de Dependent Origination
Il nous dit que le processus de conscience, pour ne pas trouver un mot mieux que celui-ci, il faut dire que ces jours, les scientifiques étudient la conscience.
Et les philosophes parlent beaucoup de la conscience.
Et aussi les philosophes parlent beaucoup de la conscience.
Et ça la débouche au fait qu'il n'y a plus que de la confusion.
Et d'ailleurs c'est pour cette raison que je n'aime pas tellement utiliser ce mot.
Cela commence avec le corps et l'esprit.
et avec cela, il y a les actes de cognition le corps et l'esprit et les actes de cognition le corps et l'esprit sont ensuite séparés dans les six sens
et le corps et l'esprit sont subdivisés ensuite dans les six sens et les six sens sont en fait l'esprit et le cerveau le complexe du mental et de l'esprit et à cette étape il y a contact
Pour un acte de cognition qui puisse se manifester, il doit y avoir trois facteurs.
Il doit y avoir un objet,
Il doit y avoir une base de sens pour pouvoir percevoir cet objet.
Et il doit y avoir cet acte de cognition.
Donc, il y a le recordeur, je le vois, et il y a l'acte de voir.
alors il y a l'enregistreur et je le vois et il y a l'acte de le voir dans mon esprit le point suivant c'est qu'on détermine si c'est plaisant ou déplaisant alors on vit dans un monde
Et ainsi nous vivons dans ce monde où il y a toujours cette dualité qui y est en fait.
Alors soit nous expérimentons les choses comme plaisantes
ou déplaisant, ou toute la rangée des émotions entre ces deux possibilités.
Et même pour ce qui est de ce qu'on pourrait appeler neutre, il y a toujours une petite teinte, soit agréable ou désagréable.
le point suivant est une relation avec ce qu'on perçoit comme étant plaisant ou déplaisant à ce point une fois que nous avons décidé cela il y a un point
c'est le point où on veut ou on ne veut pas quelque chose c'est seulement au stade suivant que le sens du soi ou du moi surgit le point de l'action
Et le point suivant est en fait l'action.
Et ça, c'est le point du Kama, à savoir l'action.
Et ainsi, nous disons, je veux une glace fantastique.
Mais psychologiquement, c'est dans l'autre sens.
Ice cream, nice, want, I, get.
Want ?
je veux je prends donc ce sens que nous avons de moi est aussi apparaissant et passant très rapidement
et donc aussi ce sens du soi ou du moi en fait surgit et passe et disparaît aussi à une fréquence rapide et ça c'est quelque chose que nous pouvons donc nous pouvons aussi faire l'expérience dans cette méditation vipassana
Et donc ça c'est vraiment quelque chose qu'on peut expérimenter directement.
à travers ces réflexions lorsque nous sommes dans la position assise et bien ça consiste juste à observer finalement ce qui apparaît sur cet écran et rien finalement ne peut être écrit comme une âme ok, maintenant on pourrait dire maintenant que le Bouddha enseigne un nihilisme un nihilisme
Alors on pourrait dire à ce stade que le Bouddha enseigne le nihilisme.
Et à ce moment, on doit aller à un autre endroit des Écritures et où le Bouddha décrit la fin de la souffrance.
Et il le dit de bien nombreuses façons.
Il le dit de nombreuses façons, mais celle qui est la plus courante c'est qu'il y a un non-né, il y a un non-créé,
et il y a un bon et un non conditionné un inconditionné il parle aussi de Ayatana Ayatana est une sphère une sphère d'un point de vue du Bouddha est
une expérience exclusive et il parle donc des six sens donc il y a une sphère de voir
Et donc il y a une sphère de vision qui est différente de la sphère de l'ouïe.
Et vous ne pouvez pas entendre avec vos yeux et voir avec vos oreilles.
Il dit qu'il y a une sphère où il n'y a pas de lune, pas de soleil,
Et ensuite, il dit, il y a une sphère où il n'y a ni soleil, ni lune.
Et en d'autres termes, cet univers, ce cosmos.
Il n'y a pas de venue, ni de départ.
Rien ne se passe.
Et ensuite, il y a une sphère où il n'y a pas de venue, ni de départ.
Et il poursuit en disant juste ceci, c'est la fin de la souffrance.
Et la citation finale, c'est lorsque quelqu'un demanda au Bouddha où cela se passe quand les quatre éléments arrivent jusqu'au bout, jusqu'à la fin.
Les quatre éléments sont la terre, le feu, l'eau et l'air.
Et en fait, ce sont des métaphores.
Et ils constituent le monde matériel.
Tout ce qui a de la pression, aujourd'hui, on appellerait ça de la gravité, ou tout au moins qui fait partie de la gravité.
La feuille est de l'énergie.
le feu c'est l'énergie l'eau c'est la cohésion c'est l'élasticité c'est ce qui rassemble c'est le facteur de rassemblement et l'air c'est le mouvement donc il demande au Bouddha où est-ce que tout ça arrive où est-ce que tout ça finit
Et il demanda donc au Bouddha, quand est-ce que ces éléments arrivent, où est-ce que ces éléments arrivent au bout, à la fin ?
Sa réponse est de dire que la question est mal formulée.
Vous devriez demander, où sont les quatre éléments qui ne trouvent pas de pied ?
vous devriez poser la question suivante où quand les quatre éléments ne trouvent pas pied et ensuite il fait ce constat qui est extrêmement clair il y a une conscience une connaissance
Il y a une conscience, une conscience, oui, qui n'est teintée d'aucune, d'aucun des six sens.
Qui n'est teintée, teintée, which means that
Ce qui veut dire que ça ne peut pas être vu, touché, senti, goûté, entendu.
Et ça ne peut pas y réfléchir, on ne peut pas en faire une conception,
Et ça ne peut pas être ressenti.
Et en plus c'est sans frontières.
Les frontières sont créées par les phénomènes.
Et donc là il n'y a rien du tout.
Et en plus dans toutes les directions est plein de lumière.
Juste cela est le fin du souffrance.
c'est juste cela, c'est la fin de la souffrance et ça, ça a l'air de ressembler à un atta qui n'est pas un atta les mêmes qualités d'éternité de substance, le vrai tout est dit dans cette sentence
Et en fait, ces qualités d'éternalité et de substance, tout ceci est intégré dans cette phrase.
C'est permanent, c'est complet en lui-même et de ce fait, c'est
heureux, si on peut dire ça, entre guillemets.
Mais, ça n'a pas de moi, de soi.
Et maintenant...
Et maintenant Bhante nous amène sur une autre piste et à travers un autre angle de vue.
Cette conscience dont le Bouddha parle,
Si nous pouvons revenir au moment où nous avons été conçus, à notre naissance.
Alors, ça se trouve en fait à l'intérieur du foetus.
Qu'est-ce que ça c'est ?
ça ne sait rien alors il croit savoir que ça commence à sentir à entendre la voix de sa maman la sensation de chaleur et puis quand il est né qu'est-ce que nous savons ?
Et ensuite, quand c'est né, qu'est-ce qu'on en sait ?
Quelque part, le long de ce parcours, il y a une identification à cette forme.
À un moment donné, jusqu'à l'âge de trois ans, le enfant devient self-aware.
Quelque part, entre la naissance et jusqu'à l'âge de trois ans, l'enfant devient conscient de lui-même.
Et les chimpanzés aussi, d'ailleurs.
C'est étonnant, hein ?
Et on peut donc voir que le...
l'erreur est vite faite je suis cet être humain qu'est-ce que nous souhaitons ?
qu'est-ce que nous désirons ?
nous voulons être heureux nous pouvons définir notre propre bonheur mais nous voulons tous être heureux donc nous cherchons la bonheur
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous allons rechercher le bonheur ce sens du soi est en fait c'est désécurisant ça a besoin de se sécuriser de se sentir vrai et tangible
L'accumulation des choses devient ensuite de l'avidité.
Plus j'ai de l'argent dans mon compte en banque et plus je me sens en sécurité.
Et parce que j'ai ces choses, je dois nécessairement les tenir.
Et parce que j'ai toutes ces choses, j'ai forcément besoin de les conserver, de les garder.
Et j'ai donc toujours peur de les perdre.
Et si jamais quelqu'un essaie de nous les prendre, et bien ce sont des personnes à détester.
Et en particulier les gouvernements.
Non !
Ici, nous avons nos attitudes basiques face à la vie.
L'envie d'acquérir.
L'aversion.
Et la peur, la crainte.
Et tout ça vient à cause de ce erreur concernant ce qu'on est réellement.
Alors, comment dépassons-nous ce erreur ?
C'est par la pratique de l'ipassana,
C'est en faisant la pratique du vipassana et en découvrant un autre lotus, un autre endroit de nous-mêmes.
Hier, j'étais un petit peu surpris que certaines personnes n'avaient pas cognisé ce sens de l'observateur.
Donc, quand vous vous asseyez en méditation, la première chose à laquelle vous pouvez vous rendre conscient est l'esprit.
Et donc, quand vous êtes assis en méditation, la première chose dont vous prenez conscience, c'est la respiration.
Le fait que vous soyez conscient de quelque chose n'est forcément pas la conscience elle-même.
Parce qu'il y a deux choses.
Il y a la conscience et l'objet.
Parce qu'en fait, il y a la conscience d'un côté et il y a l'objet de l'autre.
Donc, nous avons enlevé l'identité au corps.
Qu'est-ce qu'on veut dire par l'identification au corps ?
Avec les enfants, c'est très simple.
Mais prenez par exemple un moment où vous prenez votre doigt dans la porte.
Pour cet instant singulier, vous êtes la douleur.
Et ça, c'est l'identification au corps.
et ensuite vous revenez en arrière vous reculez et vous devenez furieux et vous donnez un coup de pied dans la porte donc l'identité avec quelque chose signifie c'est le soi c'est ce que vous pensez c'est une expérience de vous dans ce moment
et l'identification au soi c'est en fait l'expérience que nous faisons du soi à un moment donné précis dans le temps et lorsqu'il s'agit d'une émotion c'est plus facile à comprendre très souvent nous nous perdons dans des émotions dans une émotion nous nous trouvons
Nous nous trouvons comme la colère elle-même.
Nous perdons la conscience de nous-mêmes, nous sommes simplement la colère.
Nous sommes heureux, nous sommes impliqués dans quelque chose et nous perdons la conscience de nous-mêmes et nous sommes la joie.
Nous sommes heureux, nous sommes complètement absorbés dans quelque chose et nous perdons totalement le sens de nous-mêmes et nous sommes en fait ce bonheur.
Quand vous regardez un film ou un DVD pour une heure ou deux et vous êtes complètement absorbé dans ce film, vous êtes le film ou pas.
Est-ce correct ?
Dans le même sens.
Donc, il y a un esprit émotionnel.
Maintenant, quand je médite, je ressens une émotion ici.
Il y a l'awareness et l'émotion.
Alors il y a le soi émotionnel, quand vous êtes en méditation et que vous ressentez cette émotion, et bien il y a moi et il y a l'émotion.
Voilà, il me corrige, il y a cette conscience d'un côté et il y a l'émotion de l'autre.
avec les pensées, quand je me sers, parfois je deviens la pensée je pense, donc je suis mais quand ma méditation est très claire je peux voir une image parfois je peux voir un train de pensées
Mais lorsque la méditation est très claire, il m'arrive de voir les pensées passer, voire même de voir comme un train défiler toutes ces pensées qui passent à travers moi.
Et à ce moment, je suis conscient du fait qu'il y a à la fois la conscience et de l'autre côté, il y a ces pensées qui traversent mon esprit.
Et ensuite, nous arrivons au positionnement final du sens, du soi ou du moi.
Et ça, c'est le ressenti de l'observateur, de celui qui sait.
L'observer.
à ce stade là vous ne pouvez pas aller plus loin jusqu'à ce stade vous pouvez tout faire avec un acte d'intention
Si vous essayez de vous débarrasser de la conscience de soi, vous créez une autre conscience au-dessus de celle-ci qui, elle, n'aime pas cette conscience de soi-même.
Paradoxalement, ce sens de moi que nous expérimentons en nous-mêmes, en fait, pointe dans la bonne direction.
Quand vous regardez dans un mirage,
Lorsque vous vous regardez dans une glace, vous croyez que le monde vous voit comme cela.
Combien d'entre vous ont fait le test des deux miroirs ?
Non ?
Combien ?
Personne ?
Non, non, non.
D'accord.
Vous regardez dans le miroir.
Ah voilà.
voilà ce qui se passe c'est qu'en fait quand vous regardez dans le miroir le miroir inverse le visage de telle sorte que Banti explique si j'ai bien compris que si on met un autre miroir de profil il faut se regarder dans ce miroir là pour que celui-là reflète l'image de notre visage dans le premier miroir et c'est dans le premier miroir qu'on aurait
le vrai visage que les autres personnes nous voient comme les personnes nous voient si j'ai bien compris la première chose à faire en rentrant
alors ce sens de la conscience de soi alors cette conscience de soi celui qui observe
parce que nous sommes conscients du fait que nous avons conscience de nous-mêmes c'est un autre objet
Oui, cette conscience qu'on a conscience de soi, et bien cette conscience de soi ne peut être qu'un objet finalement.
Si nous-mêmes on arrive à constater qu'on a conscience de nous-mêmes, c'est comme on arrive à le constater, et bien ça peut être qu'un objet aussi.
C'est un objet.
Donc on ne peut pas être la conscience de soi-même.
Et donc, nous ne pouvons pas nous résumer à être, à nous identifier à cette conscience qu'on a de nous-mêmes.
La conscience de soi, je veux dire.
Alors, quel que ce soit qui est vrai, réel,
ça s'attrape dans le mental it captures itself so we need to keep this is only when you get to a very peaceful state ça c'est seulement quand vous réussissez à atteindre un état de calme profond so that there is complete peacefulness calmness, very great stillness
Et donc, il y a un sens de paix, de calme.
Mettez-vous directement sur la sensation, le ressenti de la conscience de soi.
Maintenant, c'est pourquoi le Bouddha dit que ceux qui sont sensibles
C'est pour ça que le Bouddha dit que ceux qui sont intentionnés sont dans la présence de Nibbana.
Ceux qui sont dans la pleine conscience de l'instant présent sont dans le Nibbana.
Non, non.
Ceux qui sont en pleine conscience sont en présence du Nibbana.
Voilà, en présence du.
Et quand...
La conclusion, c'est que quand nous sommes dans un état où nous avons conscience de nous-mêmes, nous sommes presque arrivés
Je vous ai dit que j'allais provoquer plus de confusion que d'avant.
Alors si nous passons en revue ceci, il y a trois formes d'investigation.
Nous devons investiguer cet organisme psychophysique pour voir s'il y a quelque chose de permanent.
C'est le plus facile.
Nous devons ensuite, dans notre méditation, voir le point où vient l'esprit d'identité.
Et nous devons voir dans notre méditation le point au stade duquel la notion d'identité rentre en ligne de compte.
Parce qu'en fait, ça nous enseigne et ça nous démontre que l'identité n'est pas permanente.
Par exemple, quand on dort, il n'y a pas de sens de soi-même, il n'y a pas d'identité.
Mais il y a de l'awareness.
Il y a de l'awareness.
Et enfin, dans notre méditation, quand nous arrivons au point de juste être avec cette auto-awareness,
Et en finalité, lorsque nous arrivons dans notre méditation, que nous sommes juste en présence de la conscience que nous avons de nous-mêmes, la conscience de soi, notre conscience est juste sur le ressenti de présence à l'instant.
je peux seulement souhaiter que mes mots puissent vous aider et vous assister et n'ont pas engendré plus de confusion mais ont mis le chemin vers la libération plus clairement
mais au contraire a permis de marquer le chemin qui mène à la libération de manière encore plus claire.
Et que vous puissiez par votre pratique diligente arriver à ce lieu de paix et de bonheur parfait.
Arrivez à ce stade où vous serez en paix et vous serez bien heureux.